[Music]
I think the way to optimize your impact
is to one get to know yourself really
really well like what are your skills
what do you actually have fun doing
because if you don't know yourself and
you throw yourself into something you
might like suddenly realize like
actually I don't enjoy this I'm not good
at this but I'm already committed I mean
it's a slog it doesn't feel good you
know and I think with the hat like
I love that so many people have learned
how to knit from it like my own dad
included actually but I also hope that
people get inspired to think that wait
like if knitting can make a difference
like surely like my amazing important
hobby can make a difference like you
know that you know you could just open
up the world the mind to what you can do
that it's not just one step one two
three or industry one two three it's
like for me patriarchy actually is an
idea that there's only one right way of
doing something and if that's the case
then creativity is actually the antidote
to that there's so many ways of doing
things I think not only knowing yourself
but valuing what you do I think it's so
easy to diminish what you can do
compared to what people out there can do
and finally like if once you know
yourself and you and you value what you
can do and what you like to do I think
really focusing it and not being afraid
to go big or wild or creative or off the
beaten track is really important I think
the best analogy I have for this in
particular is that if you're throwing a
party like you're the host right I think
so many women especially women feel like
it's it's um
selfish of them or egocentric to call
themselves a leader and I think host is
such an interesting word because
inherent in that word is the work right
you're opening yourself up your your or
your home up to have people over and
you're providing them with a gathering a
party and then the guests come to that
and I think for most people I would
recommend that you only choose one or
two areas of activism or to focus on to
be a host in and then you could throw
that party and that party could be a
literal fundraising party or it could be
a documentary and the guests who arrive
at that party are they watch the
documentary or they buy the documentary
right so you're spreading awareness and
so when you're not hosting a party for
your causes you can be a guest to other
people's parties and for me being a
guest means you don't actually have to
come up with invitation and secured the
venue and do all those things but you
could just show up you could show up
better March you could donate some money
you could you know watch a film and get
informed and tell others about it
so those are also important we obviously
need both but I do think some people
feel burnt out or ineffective and the
burnt how people are just host to too
many causes whilst guests while the
people who feel ineffective or lost or
without purpose can feel they might be a
guest - too many causes and they need to
find some cause that they could be a
host to
[Music]